direction maintenant le monde de la mode
avec le défilé hier dans le 8e
arrondissement de l'ancien top model
katusha ce mannequin qui a travaillé
pour les plus grands couturiers dans les
années 80 lance sa première collection
est pas facile de se faire une place
dans le prêt-à-porter pendant une
semaine pas moins de 90 défilés sont
organisés à paris vous aviez colombier
josiane szymanski l'ivresse des podiums
la lumière des flashs katusha la
panthère du saint-laurent ne s'est
jamais laissé griser pourtant l'égérie
de paco rabanne la sublime barbare de
christian lacroix
après les derniers bravo a connu les
déboires d'un monde sans pitié
une collection et puis s'en va la top
qui voulait tenir le ciseau fait
retrouver d'un seul coup à la rubrique
faits divers de quelques canards à
scandale descente aux enfers et rumeurs
assassines seulement paris couture ne
rime pas avec dallas vérité et
générosité sont encore deux saisons
katusha revient avec le prêt à porter
ça peut besoin de voir par exemple
quelqu'un comme ça de barbieux qu'elle a
depuis le début et qui était à la maison
et à farah qui me disait foot vas-y ça
va marcher de t'inquiète pas c'est beau
c'est fort ça va leur plaire et j'espère
saharienne à perdre volé au rythme des
vents du désert puis peint aux couleurs
de l'afrique a baladés harlem ou
clignancourt forfait en raphia perdant
c'est à garnier la reine de la nuit
habitait ritek effet la fête sous la
tour eiffel
la wii
ça
les prêts non la sophistication de la
parisienne et le sourire de l'afrique
visions croisées d'une voyageuse entre
deux transhumance
car larry et gérard applaudi